we are celebrating this summer our 25th
anniversary of being on the radio and so
throughout the summer into the fall
we're going to take a little time here
or there and just stop and smell the
roses along the way stop and talk about
you know some of the history of this
place and all the things that have
happened around the Dave Ramsey show up
to this point if you didn't know we're
at 586 radio stations making us the
third largest syndicated talk radio show
in America Rush being one and Sean Bing
tuned us being three and we appreciate
that appreciate all of our affiliates
out there carrying the show and every
single year for 25 years we have had
more stations than the year before we've
never gone backwards in a year-over-year
setting and because we've scratched and
clawed and you know started from the
bottom and worked our way up we own this
and we're the only one of the major talk
radio shows that you listen to out there
that is Corp that is not corporate owned
by one of the big radio companies we own
it we are happy to happy that they agree
to carry the show and that it makes them
good ratings and good money and that a
lot of you listen to it and we
appreciate that if you haven't heard the
story I started with nothing Sharon and
I got married broke I started buying and
selling real estate and I got rich at
least by kid from any octa nnessee
standards I ended up with about four
million dollars where the real estate
but I did stupid stuff and borrowed too
much money and I spent the next two and
half years of my life losing everything
we owned we were sued and foreclosed on
and finally with a brand new baby and a
toddler almost 30 years ago we were
bankrupt and had to start completely
over
we didn't bounce back we sat around and
whined and cried and blamed everybody
else for our stupidity but it was my
stupidity that put us there you ever
done something stupid and blame other
people well I did
turns out McDonald's does serve hot
coffee
now I borrowed money and it was my fault
I borrowed it stupid in the bank's
decided to call the notes I wasn't late
they just freaked out and banks do that
at different times in the economy over
the years with 30 years ago they did
that and all of a sudden flipped this
house turned on the day being flipped on
his head and we lost it and started
completely over after a while though I
began to teach a Sunday School class at
my church on God's ways of handling
money common sense that I didn't have
previously and then I learned from old
people with money live on less than you
make get out of debt save money always
be generous have a written plan these
are principles that work in good times
and in bad times and we began to talk
about it and people began to listen I
wrote a little book called financial
peace and I self-published it which
means I took it to the printer and they
printed them up nobody would buy them I
have carrying them around the trunk of
my car giving them away
my wife said we gave away the first
thousand she's probably about right on
that first thousand were expensive to
cost me forty six hundred and eighty two
dollars all right so why that's four
dollars and 67 cents a piece
you know I don't pay that for the books
now thirty years later so we wrote that
little book and I went on a radio
station radio show on a broke radio
station they were in chapter 11
bankruptcy and I went on as a guest a
couple of times and the phone rang while
I was on because we were talking about
helping people with money and boom it
took off and radio station was wtn in
Nashville we're talking Nashville and
that guy quit because they weren't
paying him his $35 and a buddy of mine
in the insurance business named Roy
called me Roy Matlock and said hey me
and you ought to go down and do that
radio show and I said I don't want to a
radio show
there is no money in radio I need to
feed my kids I'm hungry and he goes well
you know it's only an hour a day I could
do a couple days a week you do a couple
days a week and who knows you might
himself so much stupid little book you
wrote and so we went down and talked to
a guy named David Manning making in
Hollywood Manning David still in the
business I think he's last time I talked
to him he's with a rock station down in
Jacksonville Florida and David and his
infinite wisdom agreed to let us work
for free figuring he could fire us at
any moment we laughed and said if we're
really bad you can cut our salary in
half but we were really bad and he still
didn't virus it gave us some odd spots
that was our compensation we could sell
or trade the ad spots to somebody the ad
spots for six dollars a minute which
means for a hundred ad spots we could
get $600 worth of something if you could
talk somebody into advertising on this
radio station that nobody listened to
and so we went on the air in the summer
of 1992 and we were bad I mean we were
really bad we were corny we're still
corny we were southern we're still
southern but we were more corny and more
southern back then
closed-circuit to those of you that are
my friends in the banking business just
kidding just kiddin I get a bunch of
letters from you people lighten up
what is having some fun it's okay no we
don't think everybody's a bankers a
crook that means the same way with the
people in the insurance business we
don't we don't have anything personally
against any of them I mean we just have
a differing opinion when it comes to
this the products you know what what's
going on there so sure up gas and you
have a radio show 7:3 you're just not
fair Roy 90 Anjaneya tends to be right
more vocal more right yes that's it
seven three seven nine nine eight six
and one eighty Darryl his other brother
Darryl do talk radio and it is amazing
so we actually did
end up at Roy quit and I kept going of
course and I ended up bringing in a
voice coach from a broadcast school to
teach me how to say ice instead of ice
and going instead of going and W instead
of W and so on and sometimes I do it
right still I didn't we didn't
intentionally didn't keep working on it
long enough to remove all of my southern
accent because I'm not ashamed of my
southern heritage I just didn't want to
sound like I was broadcasting from a
double-wide there's a lot of you people
in Boston still think I am stereotypes
run pretty deep in this country which
are based on ignorance of course but
very very fun stuff and you know we just
we stumbled along and you know what was
interesting from the very first day the
phone rang and no matter how bad we were
at broadcast delivery people could tell
we cared and they could tell that we
wanted to help them and they called for
help
25 years later they still are we're
going to talk a little bit about this a
little bit more coming back in the next
break 25 year anniversary this year of
the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]
so we're taking a little trip down
memory lane and taking your calls for
the rest of the show the phone numbers
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two two five the summer of 1992
I went on the air with two other friends
Roy Matlock and Howell Wilson Hal did a
real estate theme our own Friday and Roy
did a couple days a week and I did a
couple days a week the show was called
the money game and I had hair and I had
big mr. Magoo glasses and a really
really thick southern accent to say the
least
and you know I think I was actually
nicer than uh to my it's not that my
patience has run short it's just that
over 25 years of answering a lot of
times the same question um I just don't
suffer arguing with fools like I used to
I used to be kind and want to just
convince somebody that was foolish now
just home don't be foolish and you know
it's it's a good radio either way I mean
but I think I was a lot more syrupy and
kind of sweet teeth in and I'm probably
just a stiff shot a Red Bull now but
it's funny how things change over time
and of course the longer you do
something the better you get at it
hypothetically if you work at it and so
we see things around here and the calls
and then the colors that we didn't see
back then we got conned a lot more back
then by the caller today we can see
through their crap a lot quicker all of
us around here Kelly and me and James
all of us included while we're doing the
show and we went on the air the radio
station was a menagerie it was a WKRP
from Cincinnati so there were some
really good broadcasters on the shows at
the time in the morning and there's been
real professional guys in the afternoon
doing a sports show that was the only
thing on there that had any ratings to
amount anything the morning show had a
little bit of ratings and rest of us
were just a bunch of zoo animals they
just put on the air
because they could get up for free or
close to free and the thing was in
chapter 11 bankruptcy the lady that did
the we did a show from 10:00 in the
morning to 11 the lady that did the show
from 11 to 12 would read your palm over
the air was a palm reading talk radio
show I am not making this up
you can't make this crap up now I'm
telling you it was crazy it was a bunch
of characters and some of them I still
see from time to time always fun to run
into them and brings back memories it's
almost like running to your old high
school buddies or something right or
your old college buddies or something
that brings back the crazy memories and
stuff people did we were doing a show
one day and they had this young guy that
was new that was the quote-unquote
program director which was kind of a
joke really and he decided while we were
on the air that he was going to come in
to the studio and drop his trousers and
munis and he was a large boy and I saw I
mean this was yeah and we're supposed to
just keep talking like nothing happened
right we did we kept talking like
nothing we never even broke a smile we
just kept going and you know he thought
that's the funniest thing he's ever done
in his life and I think he was still in
college or something that was just
unbelievable but yeah this is the kind
of crap went on in these studios back
then I mean oh that hadn't happened
since I can tell you that what was weird
was though the show started getting a
following from the very first day people
listened and started talking about it
and it might have been because it was so
bad in terms of the delivery the
information was good it was pretty much
the same information not as polished and
not as clearly delivered probably but it
was the same principles I'm getting out
of debt and cutting up your credit cards
and living on less than you make and
being on a plan and being in agreement
with your spouse and
having an emergency fund investing
long-term to build wealth Roy was in the
investing business so he was looking for
investing leads back then and that was
you know when he was getting out of
doing the show I was hoping to sell some
neat little books for $12 figured out
pretty quick you got to sell a lot of
$12 anything to eat and so it really was
not a moneymaker as a matter of fact I
first think the first six years we did
the radio show we lost money on it it
didn't make us money and or cost us
money to get to do the show when we
started syndicating the show we bought
satellite time and didn't have any
advertisers on the national network
which wasn't a national network at at
for cities and so nobody wanted
advertising across four cities I was
kind of a joke and so we couldn't make
our satellite money back except by
selling books or seminar tickets or
something and so we lost money for the
first many many years on it but it was a
good loss leader in the sense that it
this microphone has always caused you
folks to do business with us and we've
always appreciated that then that little
show led to another show and we ended up
the the station got sold to Gaylord
Entertainment and we figured at that
point we were all getting ready to be
fired because Gaylord owns Opryland
Opryland Hotel and at that time owned
the two countries two of the country
stations here in Nashville so we figure
that's another s FM radio station is
going to be a talk radio of Gaylord
Owens that we're all getting ready to be
country and so they're getting ready to
punt us and put country music on and
they did some research and found out how
many listeners we had and they decided
to keep a talk radio which turned out to
be a brilliant thing on their part
because they made about 60 or 70 million
dollars profit on the radio station when
they sold it later and they came in and
started teaching us how to do radio
because no one we didn't even say the
coal liners you guys which is just
straight-up illegal you're supposed to
say the call letters and once an hour
all the time you know the local radio
station is supposed to put their call
letters out the network show like this
I'm going to do
a network show but that you know my
affiliates right now I'll have to say
the call letters at least once around we
never said the caller's at one time for
40 years I was on there I didn't even
know I mean I'd say wtn occasionally
just because I thought it sounded cool
but you know and so they came back
started teaching us to do to actually
say the call letters and actually brand
the radio station and all of a sudden
our ratings went way up because people
actually knew who they were listening to
it was amazing and so we went from not
even appearing in the ratings book to
being one of the top shows in the entire
city within about five ratings books
which meant there was much people
listening that weren't writing it down
the ratings because they didn't know
they were listening to so it's called
phantom cumin our world and so anyway we
learned all of that stuff and and
started cleaning up our act and being
more professional broadcasters in quotes
some question if I've ever arrived at
that I doubt that I have but it's
working out okay we've got almost 600
affiliates so probably going to end up
being a broadcaster one of these days
put me in a couple of Hall of Fame's
over it's I don't know but um you know
we'll stumble into it I guess before
it's over but so we continued on that
journey in that end and these geniuses
at Gaylord decided they were going to
move our show to the afternoon and they
wanted to give us not one hour but three
hours and put me up head-to-head against
Rush Limbaugh and Sean Hannity which
were the hottest things on the planet
and I well that'll be about the end of
the Hat because you know you go up
against Elvis and rock and roll you
pretty much get beat right and so I'll
be done after this and you guys are just
you're setting me up to die here they
said no if you just even show up good
against him then other stations will
want to carry you because nobody's got
the antidote to rush and worked out
pretty good because for many many many
years in that time slot in Nashville we
beat rush head-to-head and we beat Sean
head-to-head now they whip my but in
most markets don't misunderstand but
this is our home turf and station we
were on was a great station in those
days very well run very well programmed
and
we were part of it and we mean we call
it a wave and so we were beating Hannity
and beating Rush and so stations all
over America decide they will start
carrying the Dave Ramsey show and that's
the beginnings of how this whole thing
happened so we'll do a few more walks
down memory lane as we go along through
the rest of the summer celebrating our
25 years here on the air thank you for
listening if you're a brand-new listener
if you've been with us that whole time
we appreciate it this is the Dave Ramsey
show
[Music]
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh